a trained boxer throwing a punch is
capable of generating around 5,000
newtons of force that's roughly half the
force that a one ton car exerts on the
ground a martial artist delivering a
well-executed kick meanwhile can exert
around 9,000 Newtons at the same time
the top face balled pictures are capable
of throwing balls at a speed of over 100
miles an hour that's insane
how is the human body capable of
generating such incredible power the
answer has a lot to do with a function
of your body that you may not be aware
of the syrup effect the syrup effect
refers to the diagonal arrangement of
many muscles in your torso specifically
these are the rhomboids the serratus
anterior the external obliques and the
internal obliques together these muscles
wrap around the back and form an X shape
across the abdominal region at the front
the resulting image is similar to the
mexican syrup which is what gives the
effect its name in short our musculature
is designed to link the left shoulder to
the right hip and vice versa this effect
can be seen as soon as you throw a ball
you'll find that you naturally raise
your throwing hand back pulling your
shoulder back as you do and that your
hip on the opposite side comes forwards
what you're effectively doing here is
winding up the body you are stretching
the muscles responsible which in turn
then allows you to exert the maximum
amount of power when you put your entire
body into the throw this is as opposed
to keeping the body steady and simply
throwing the ball with your arm which
puts a lot less mass behind the movement
and involves far fewer muscles the same
thing is true for a great punch or kick
the power comes from the rotation of the
entire body which engages as much muscle
mass as possible
this is absolutely key to the way the
human body was designed to move we see
it when we walk the left hip comes
forward as the right shoulder moves
backwards giving us a contralateral arm
swing we also see it when we look at the
brain the left side of the brain is
primarily wired to control the right
side of the body and vice versa it's a
key factor in a huge number of sports
from a tennis serve to a javelin throw
to a punch or a kick this is why it is
so extremely important that you train in
the transverse plane using movements
that twist the body so many conventional
training programs completely ignore
these muscles which in turn means you
are completely
prepared to deliver serious power from
your limbs so how can we do this one of
the best examples of all is to use their
medicine ball throw and throw it using
hip rotation you can do this with a
rotational throw or the shotput throw
either way the medicine ball allows you
to Train power generation as you can
exert as much force as you want
when slinging the heavy ball another
excellent option is sledgehammer
training hitting a tire with a
sledgehammer again allows for ballistic
strength in this range of motion for
developing strength you can train using
cable moves like the Wood chop or the
cable punch out anti rotational
movements are also excellent for this
such as the one-handed pusher
lizard crawls and other quadrupedal
movements are also great examples of
contralateral training and can similarly
help to build strength from these areas
along with the inter muscular
coordination necessary to engage them
together the Turkish getup actually has
similar benefits in my last video I
explained how Bruce Lee's core stability
ultimately allowed him to deliver more
powerful punches by creating a rigid
body in the kinematic chain some
commenters asked whether this would make
them stiff and rigid
wouldn't that be counterproductive
especially as a martial artist is
supposed to be loose until the moment of
impact and what about martial arts
tricking or gymnastics but of course the
purpose of cost ability training is not
to permanently lock yourself in a rigid
position instead the aim is to give you
that option and it's by transitioning
between loose and whip like and then
solid intense then you can exert the
maximum amount of force now water can
flow or it can crash be water my friend
in this case you'll be loose as you
relax and wind up the muscles then
contract at the moment of impact
specifically you'll tighten the core so
that the fist can be driven into the
target and you'll clench the fist to
harden the forearms and the surrounding
region via irradiation if you stayed
loose at this point the impact would
lose some kinetic energy as your body
reversed that twisting motion the
ultimate goal is perfect muscle control
so as to relax any muscle working in an
antagonistic fashion while contracting
the rest at the perfect moment to
deliver maximum impact part of this
power is achieved through another effect
called the stretch shortening cycle this
refers to the rebound effect that muscle
has after being stretched
of course lengthening the muscle will
always provide greater distance for
power to be generated but the key is
speed the faster you stretch and then
shorten the muscle the more
power you're capable of generating this
is where you can jump much higher by
swinging the arms up squatting down and
then launching back up this is called a
counter movement jump first is simply
jumping out of a squat position the
stretch shortening cycle is likewise
something that can be trained which is
why using ballistic type exercises such
as the medicine ball throw it is
particularly good for developing the
kind of power that will translate into
powerful throws and punches this is also
why kinetic linking is so important in
martial arts throwing a punch and then
placing your hips and shoulders in the
perfect position for the next strike
ready to generate the maximum amount of
power and to utilize some of that stored
kinetic energy ground - recently posted
a video on this subject that has been
invaluable to my own training it's
absolutely fantastic to go and check it
out and this is also why martial arts in
particular translate so incredibly well
to general athleticism you can also find
some more examples of training for the
syrup effects over on my instagram at at
the pioneer and if you like this kind of
philosophical approach to training and
human performance then be sure to check
out my ebook and training program super
functional training you can find a link
to that in the description down below
and there's currently a discount on
seeing as everyone is trapped indoors at
the moment and could probably use
something to read I hope you enjoyed
this video guys if you did then please
leave like a comment and share it around
that helps me out immensely subscribe if
you want to see more like this and of
course I'll see you next time thanks ton
for watching and bye for now
you